Russia's president is imposing martial
law in the four regions Moscow annexed
from Ukraine Vladimir Putin is also
giving additional emergency powers to
the heads of all regions of Russia this
comes after Russia's military suffered
major defeats and a counter-offensive by
Ukrainian forces in September the
Russian army has admitted that it is
facing a very difficult situation in the
southern region of Curson as key pushes
to retake the area thousands of
civilians there are being evacuated
let me remind you that in the
territories of the donets People's
Republic the lahence People's Republic
as well as the zapparicia and kosan
regions martial law was in effect before
they joined Russia now we need to
formalize this regime already within the
framework of the Russian legislation
therefore I signed a decree on the
introduction of Martial law in these
four entities of the Russian Federation
it will be immediately sent to the
Federation Council for approval
is in the Ukrainian Capital Kiev but
first let's go to Muhammad Val in Moscow
Muhammad is it fair to say these moves
reflect the increasing pressure the
Russian military is feeling
but there is no doubt uh Cyril that the
Russians are preparing for a new phase a
new move the new mode of action in
eastern and southern Ukraine after the
weeks of defeats that everybody has seen
and the Russians are unhappy with that
the leadership has been preparing these
things here we have seen the the
appointment of Sergey sorovicin who was
head of the the operation in Syria and
he's known for his tough-handedness in
these types of situations and we have
seen the new campaign of airstrikes
across Ukraine after the uh the uh the
bridge explosion uh some days ago so all
of these come together and this
declaration of Martial laws today has
been awaited as one of the measures that
the Russians are expecting at least at
the the highest levels of decision
making expecting to show that the
leadership has more measures to take
more action to take and has not come to
the limitations or the limits of what it
can do in this war they want to reverse
the situation that's going on in the
east and south of of Ukraine
they want to prove to their people here
that they can gain victory in this war
so a special counsel for coordination is
going to be set up and vast powers given
to the local Governors for Russian
Governors and also martial law of me is
that the military can do most of what
they couldn't do in the past under the
law they can restrict movements of
people they can force people for into
mobilization this is no longer a partial
mobilization particularly in those four
regions and even the industry that has
been like civilian civilian Industries
will be probably oriented to to towards
military
Industries and and production to help
the military everything from now on will
be will be used to serve the purpose of
victory in in this war and uh also we
don't know what else can be done in
terms of the type of weapons the type of
tactics that they are going to follow uh
to make a difference on the ground
Mohammed Val reporting from Moscow thank
you very much Russia says a